- [Voiceover] We just
derived what the current is
and the voltage.
These are both the natural
response of the RC.
Now what I did is I went
ahead and I plotted out this
using a computer, just using Excel,
to plot out what these
two expressions look like,
and let me show you that.
So let's do a real quick example here
with real values just to
see how this equation works.
We'll say that this is 1,000 ohms.
That's our resistor.
And we'll say C is one microfarad.
And what we wanna work out is R times C
equals 10 to the third
times 10 to the minus six
and that equals 10 to
the minus three seconds
or one millisecond.
That's the product of R and C.
I forgot V-naught.
Let's say we put two
volts on this capacitor
to start with, like that.
And now we can say V of
t equals V-naught two volts
times e to the minus t
over one millisecond.
And that's our natural response
for this particular circuit.
Now let me show you what that looks like.
This is V of t on this side.
Equals two e to the minus
t over one millisecond.
And you can see it starts at two volts
and then sags down as we predicted,
and that's an exponential curve.
And then over here on this side,
i, as we said before, starts out at zero
in the capacitor, the current
in the capacitor is zero,
and as soon as we throw open that switch,
the charge charges over
through the resistor
and this is the equation here, i of t
equals two volts over 1,000
e to the minus t over RC or
t over one millisecond.
So this is what we call
the natural response
of an RC circuit, and you'll run into this
in almost every circuit you ever build.